there are more than just two comic book
publishers you know so I've got no real
set up for this don't know why I felt
like doing it but I wanted to do my pick
for the top ten movies based off of
comic books that are not comic book
properties originally published through
either DC or marvel those are my only
requirements for this list let's get
right to it with number 10 Sin City I
think you would be hard-pressed to find
too many other projects that did such a
fantastic job of taking what was on the
page and translating it directly onto
the screen and doing it so starkly is
what cuz I mean Sin City as a comic book
is incredibly stylized so to make a film
that was just as stylized as the comic
book and have it work
visually and actually makes sense and
flow that was that was really cool and
it's I mean Sin City is so overwrought
as a property but they got you know a
director who's good with that sort of
stuff they got actors who by and large
could handle this sort of overwrought
archness ridiculousness and there's
there's really not much else out there
like it the reason I won't put it higher
on the list is I I honestly feel that
the segmented three things doesn't quite
work and I kind of wish they had cut
between them a little bit more and
enjoyed them that way and had them all
sort of climax together from coming
between them rather than having it
segment segment segment but that's a
personal preference thing but still good
movie number nine
kick-ass now if I'm being completely
honest the the part of the reason this
isn't going to go higher than nine is
that the best things about this movie
aren't the title character best things
about this movie is a Hit Girl and Big
Daddy just those characters and the way
they're executed and this is so much fun
it's just great that said kick-ass
himself is pretty interesting I like I
like the fun that this movie has
especially compared to how really darkly
cynical the original source material was
the film has
more genuine and authentic sense of fun
about everything that's going on and and
that is kind of infectious and you feels
like yeah as it's going through even as
it sort of departs from its original
premise of what if superheroes are real
and it gets more and more and more
outlandish as the movie goes on but it
just bounces it really well and it's fun
then you go with it and it's a good time
number eight Scott Pilgrim vs. the world
I'm sure there are some people who would
have put this way higher on their list
and I do really like this movie but I
think what I love about it is the visual
presentation of it there are things
about the story that I don't think are
bad but don't quite land with me or door
I just don't connect with me quite in
the right way but in terms of visuals
it's actually funny to think of this as
a comic book movie because I tend to
almost think of it more as a videogame
movie because it's got videogame
structure you've got the seven bosses to
get through it side speaking in a video
game language between the audio and
visual callbacks to video games which is
obviously in the comic book as well but
putting it on the screen and getting you
know that sort of the splash of things
and you know they they fall into coins
and you know hundred points or whatever
just it makes it read I think even more
than it does on the comic book page
where it's you're more just sort of oh
there's a little goof but somehow see
that integrated to a live-action here is
at home a little bit more and it's just
a fun weird story with fun weird
characters and fun weird non sequiturs
and it's just it just bounces along has
it takes you through this through this
trip and these fights and the fights are
awesome and just like it
lalla number seven 300 I know I had said
when I brought up Sin City you would be
hard-pressed to find a better you know
translation from the comic book to the
screen I would say I think I think this
one doesn't slightly better because it
managed to in a few cases recreate comic
panels but then sort of fill it out in
between with stuff that is more unique
to the film and not direct lifts from
Frank Miller's original work but still
all felt very of a piece and it all felt
unified now I know they repeat some
people who take a lot of issue with 300
and
call it a fascist film they and you know
things like that I'm not gonna say that
those people are wrong I am going to say
for my part those fascist overtones
don't bother me because they're so
overblown I have a hard time thinking
that anyone could really take them
seriously and especially if you sort of
add the layer of remember all of this is
being retold by David when times
character so he's actually laying this
out basically as a pump up the army
propaganda piece remember how great
these guys were as you go and fight the
Persian army so I always kind of went in
assuming that it was intentionally
overly embellished and all this other
stuff in and whether that was
intentional or not basically sort of
gives me an out to be okay with it so
setting all that stuff aside just
visually Oh back before we were all sick
of Scott Snyder and the speed ramping
and everything else it's the speed
ramping here honestly works really well
the way things are filmed the effects
look great and it just it commits to
atoning I think that's another reason
that I don't get hung up on sort of the
the quote unquote pillar I don't think
the movie has enough brain to actually
have a political message but the
political stuff that some people take
issue with but to me I just like that
the thing commits to being absolutely
this thing that it is instead of just
measuring is like no we're going all in
and whether you enjoy the film or not I
think you kind of have to respect that
to a certain extent and for my part I
just I really enjoy this movie number
six a history of violence probably the
most grounded thing that's gonna be on
this list is one of those movies that I
think people tend to forget was
originally a comic book kind of like
road to perdition in that sense the road
to perdition for a spoiler is not on
this list a little too pretentious but
this feels very solid and grounded and
until the violence breaks out you go
Paul David Cronenberg is an interesting
filmmaker and he does he makes
interesting choices when he sort of sets
aside his usual tropes of body horror
and the sci-fi your horrific elements
because there's still some horrible
stuff that goes on in here but it's it's
all based and grounded in reality and to
see it sort of root
in that way in it well it makes the
violence hit harder it makes it a little
bit more disturbing and the performances
are terrific Viggo Mortensen is great in
this I always love hit Harris but lest
we forget William Hurt at the end oh
such good stuff number five Kingsman the
Secret Service I think I just saw this
at the right time I am pretty sure it
was after I had seen Spectre and been
thoroughly disappointed with it to see
this sort of in a way takedown but also
reeling in reaffirmation of the British
gentleman spy I saw it at the right time
but it also much like kick-ass which
fittingly enough same director based off
material written by the same original
creator but it has that just that same
level of joyousness and that reverence
in terms of what it's tackling and I
don't want to say spoofing cuz it's not
a spoof it does it with who with this
surprising degree of sincerity but just
the gadgets and the suits and the
training and Colin for that that fight
in the church holy cow and the
ridiculousness of everything going on
but the sincerity that they tackle it
with and it's fun and it's funny and
Samuel Jackson and doing a character
that you never would have thought you
would have played it like that but it's
great there is a reason that despite the
fact that we've not had a trailer yet
that the sequel is one of my most
anticipated movies of this year number
four Hellboy 2 the golden army the
original Hellboy is pretty good but I
think and so it added some elements that
I don't think word necessary the main
one being the character of Meyer and
this whole sort of POV character
thankfully Hellboy 2 scratched him
completely so that we can hang out with
the monsters which is why we're here a
nice movie focused completely on our
monster heroes ditching the whole old
the world can't know about them thing
and just letting Hellboy be Hellboy
being in the middle of street shooting
is big ass gun a big-ass monster I mean
visually this movie is stunning the
effects are amazing
how much of it was practical even the
CGI is really good I love the sense of
wonder I love the fairytale aspects of
it this is the kind of fantasy that I
particularly really enjoyed this sort of
an Arctic wild world that humans don't
really know about and really have no
real shot at understanding and I'd love
just little glimpses of that and of
course Ron Perlman and Doug Jones front
and center as hell boy and a bee yeah
this is great getting up there now
number three the crow Oh Brandon Lee you
went too early now I this is a personal
list this is a personal favorites list
and if I am being completely honest it's
possible that somebody watching this for
the first time who wasn't there at the
time around 4:00 90s goth culture and
kind of only knows it yo has a more
historical or in fact maybe the movie
doesn't hold up so much but as someone
who was around grew up in that yeah it's
a it's a it's just so awesome I love the
feel of it I love the vibe of it I love
Brandon Lee's performances it's got a
fantastically despicable villain I
always liked her Ernie Hudson and the
whole thing in a way and this is gonna
sound horrible but in a way I almost
feel like the fact that it was Brandon
Lee's last film it almost adds
additional weight to a movie that was
already really good there's just
something about knowing what happened
and he has the character has a point
later on where he actually gets hurt and
the cop car says I thought you were
invincible and he says I was and this
that that line now has just had so much
weight and I don't know if I can credit
the movie with that cuz obviously it
wasn't supposed to he wasn't supposed to
die while filming this thing but and it
adds weight on a movie that is already
just dripping with style and darkness
but like it it believes in its darkness
this wasn't a studio executive going
darker Zinn make something dark now this
this thing inhabits it it is truly of
that world it's not playing at being
dark it is that
[ __ ] you can tell the difference number
two men in black know I do not consider
the original to be tainted by the
sequels cuz yeah the as a franchise no
but that original film oh it's so good
it's so fun it's so funny the chemistry
between Tommy Lee Jones and Will Smith
is phenomenal it's a very good
self-contained story of yes it's set up
for sequels but the sequel shouldn't
have had Tommy Lee Jones he was done
that was kind of the point in a way but
I but moving off from that I just love
the whole premise like aliens they're
everywhere they're just here they're not
bothering anybody but there is an agency
that it it's there to keep tabs on them
and to and to help these things out and
I love how Will Smith is just you know
he's facing these giant bugs and the
world's at stake and Tommy Lee Jones
it's just another day at the office so
many films try to do the unflappable
character and they can't sell it I don't
know if they can't get the right actor
or if they don't have the right sort of
additional character to balance that out
which Will Smith does and with Tommy Lee
Jones in this but I love how just work
at hey Tommy Lee Jones and Zedd and all
those other characters are well Will
Smith is he's about as will Smithee as
he is in anything and this is a case
where it absolutely works sometimes his
Will Smith or isms don't fit like say
Wild West bomb nothing fit in that but
here that kind of reaction to every DC
is the perfect counterbalance to how
little the people who are already doing
the job think about what it is that they
do it's nothing to them it's crazy to
him it's well cast as well balanced as
well shot it's fun action it's great
ideas it's great and my number one comic
book movie based off of a comic book
could not owned by Marvel or DC dread
this movie had no business being any
good at all none it just it didn't Judge
Dredd Sylvester Stallone should have
killed this thing dead and unfortunately
actually it might have because I have a
feeling that the memory of that
what hurt this thing's box often
probably why we're never going to get a
sequel but man oh man this movie nails
dread yeah and not just the superficial
stuff the superficial stuff is nice like
the fact that he never takes his helmet
off but understanding that dread himself
doesn't have an arc he is a force of
nature of force of the law in this case
he doesn't need an arc he is the rock
everything moves around him cuz he will
not move so the villain has to react to
him you give him a partner who is
reacting to him and around him but he
just stays the course Carl urban as
Dredd is perfect
the rookie judge who I didn't think was
gonna work at all especially when you
find out she's psychic I'm like really
they made that work the small mode they
justify the use of the technique in the
narrative and then doe sees there oddly
beautiful as terrible stuff goes on Lena
Headey is wonderfully despicable as mama
and this thing nails the pitch-black
humour of the comic cuz just read the
comic can be very funny but in a really
sick way and soak in this movie so those
are my picks for the best movies based
off comic books that are not DC or
marvel what are your thoughts on it
what's your favorite what ones did I
miss out because I know there are some
very good ones I put on this list so
what are your picks or at the very least
what's your number one whatever it is
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe hit that little bell down
there so you get notifications when new
stuff goes up check me out on twitter at
council of geeks kibbles in the council
of geeks podcast available on iTunes and
stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]